i am into my finance but you know that
i'm not into the boring side of finance
neither are you you just want your money
to do what you need it to do something
else yeah and that's where revolut come
in look at that touch that as a car how
quality does that feel
does that feel good the look of the card
that says lawrence mckenna on it look
i'm not going to show you the back
because i know what you guys are like
and not only that but i've got it on my
iphone as well so i can just double tap
apple pay thanks see you later away i go
not only that but it helps me track all
those finances so every time i spend
something i've got it all logged down
there makes nice and easy for me you'd
think that that would be a lot easier
than it is but revolut make it easy
that's the point i love it but i think
you'll love it too which is why if you
go download the app right now you get a
20 pound bonus if you hit our link in
the description get any of your choice
of card because there are a couple of
choices of cards you don't have to just
take this one
i could have drawn my own design on this
on the website it says oh do you want to
put your own little design on that and i
could have put my own design yeah
no i just want a black card thank you
very much so anyway you get your choice
of card and then after three
transactions that means you will get a
20 pound welcome offer so all you got to
do is just go into your local corner
shop sure just tap that there sure i'll
just tap that there whatever oh do i
need to put it in the machine because
you don't have contact list because you
know you're an old guy who just runs a
little corner shop and hasn't quite
caught up with the 21st century it's all
right this goes everywhere mate i get
the discounts with nike if you go to
certain restaurants
it's nike we're in the uk yeah well
we're in the world brian up to 40 off
yes please so check out the ab link in
the description below go take a look at
it you're supporting true geordi as well
by supporting yourself by getting one of
these bad boys look after yourself and
look after us at the same time
absolutely a great product everyone's a
winner now let's dive back in
[Music]
we we opened up the uh the old instagram
the old insta live vision we've asked
you a lot what you want us to talk about
first up
youtube boxing
uh it's back
there's
it there's some great things and some
not so great things so right
wow you're really selling this should we
start with the good stuff by the way if
anyone wants brian to commentate on
their fights or wants him to be ringside
for any of this stuff it's this kind of
commentary that people pay the big bucks
for tonight guys there's some good stuff
and some not so good stuff welcome to
the boxing i would like to do that and
just be completely honest because i
think a lot of the time
on sky design and all these other
platforms pretend you do see a lot of
hiding and you shouldn't you tell the
audience the truth right what you see is
good evening welcome back we've got some
big fights coming up for you tonight of
course we don't know what's going to
happen in any of them and that's what
makes this exciting and what they don't
understand is that's not what's exciting
about this they miss sell it but the
positives are
ksi is coming back to boxing it's
happening
real i'm in and from what i'm hearing
and i can't go into too much detail
but i do think the road map is 100 ksi
fights jake paul in the next 12 to
18 months at some point yeah in the next
year by the end of next year wow we
should have seen that fight and jake
paul according to eddie hearn
is fighting tommy fury this august as
well so that puts them in a direct
because the fact that they're both
fighting in august means that they can
sort of match each other on the road to
fighting each other and of course the
similar opponents as well you know we're
looking at tommy on one side huge boxer
alex wasabi obviously he's equal
potentially alex wassabi it might be
there's rumors of dylan danis which i
think would be wow that's a big step and
that's a big fight to come back to it
good name he's technically a fighter
yeah so i get that but he's a fighter
who never fights and his last fight was
against some security guard who turned
out to be a chocolatier according to
michael bisping wow um that's actually
who choked him out i would say and dylan
danis the one the one thing he is known
for is that jiu jitsu and there he was
getting
tapped out at side of a nightclub in
america right the point is tap on the
lindor um i'm excited jj have you seen
this transformation picture this one wow
yeah the guy the guy's got abs this is
at radio one's big weekend as well so
he's willing to go as low as that so
this is the this is the first time we've
seen him in shape shape look at that
[__] chain as well
the last time he bought box because he
obviously ballooned a little bit i heard
of our boy earlier uh that uh he was at
an event and jj basically is being very
strict in his diet in his commitments
right you know like bedtime and all
sorts of [__] it's like really yeah yeah
he said that's a great excuse you know
what you know when elliot's chewing your
ear off an event and he goes yeah gotta
go bed bedtime yeah um jj what are you
still here it's 4am i thought you went
to bed yeah yeah
sure
so yeah yeah
um
so so ksi's coming back we don't know
what to expect we've seen we've had
three years or something
with no fighting from jj so there's a
lot of progress that can be made in that
time and you don't know i mean he he's
also gone to music so he's dedicated a
lot of time to that he sort of feels
like he's nailed that so back into the
box so there's there's the unknown
because
ksi from logan paul 1 to logan paul 2.
in my opinion there wasn't anywhere near
enough progress made in those two fights
um if you look at the trajectory of jake
if we're being brutally honest here jake
is
i think until recently made a lot of big
jumps and then in the woodley fights i
felt like it was a bit of a regression
but maybe that's because there was a far
better fighter in front of him sure it
feels like a regression because the
chart's meant to go like that isn't it
yeah well chart went it yeah yeah and
that does happen yeah it could be fair
to all fighters you see some fighters
they go from fight to fight where
there's not a jump and then the next
fight there's a huge jump so the graph
doesn't go like that automatically
always um i'm looking at them both and
i'm really intrigued to see
where this goes um i think jj
is claiming his style is totally
different now
and i think obviously it would have to
be because by his own admission i'm sure
he looks back at the logan fights and
think you know what that wasn't boxing
it was him going for a brawl falling
with style
it was a little bit he was falling in a
bit and it was it was a brawler i mean
it was badass don't get me wrong he was
running after logan paul [__] trying
to take his [__] head off yeah but at
the same time if you do that against the
jake paul who was now a lot more skilled
than logan was back then although
logan's also improved jake paul would
have timed that and he would have took
him out yeah if i'm being aggressive
brutally honest especially if he can
time actual fighters
yeah it was ironically it was quite
similar to the nate robinson sort of
fight where you're just running after
someone trying to take his head off
right um and
now jj is going to have to come with a
lot more stereotypical boxing techniques
now does that change things a little bit
in terms of the actual spectacle that we
get that's the kind of the worry isn't
it in a good way but you you say in a
good way because you're thinking about
it from a boxing perspective yeah a lot
of people
what we're finding out is actually just
want to see a brawl they actually
they're actually there for a you know
just go after him and go head hunting
yeah that's not
boxing really it's not boxing in every
sense is it yeah i get it sometimes the
more you learn the less entertaining
becomes you become jose mourinho
yeah and there is a there's a potential
for that but i don't think so when it
comes to jake and jj because the emotion
that goes
each other's [__] head off and i
think that that
i think jake in his last fight against
woodley looked a bit flat didn't look uh
like his fundamentals were as good as
the gimbal fight even um i think jj has
got the personality to bring out the
best in both of them that's the other
aspect to think of this kind of head-on
collision between the two when you've
got woodley or even tommy fury you know
to be fair tommy obviously comes with a
big name he doesn't really come with the
personality to be able to match shape
there are very few people with a
personality
yeah and jj
comes with the numbers comes with the
backing he comes with a country of his
own bro jake paul was the third best
paid boxer in the world last year to
ornitha canelo alvarez
number one and tommy's brother tyson
heavyweight champion of the world yeah
he made over 30 million last year and i
you we already know jj is making
shitloads of cash and has a huge profile
yeah so i mean if he's if he's got that
amount of money to lose on luna then
[__] me sorry about that yes uh and and
uh jj
this is the thing they can make one of
the biggest fights in of the decade
sponsored by prime like what we seen
with logan and ksi was fantastic don't
get me wrong but this this would surpass
everything because
that what jake has went and done by
knocking out real mma world champions
has legitimized himself to a degree i
know there's still people saying he
hasn't fought a box sure whatever that's
not really the point and i think people
are sort of missing that point yeah
right he's massive now
but but the production is also improving
so i think you know from from when you
first commentated on the first jj fight
which was jj versus joella and then
there was jj vs logan i've got to admit
in production terms there wasn't the
jump up we thought there was going to be
there is a legitimacy now to all of this
production so it begins to become a bit
more oh i could put money into that it's
not just sort of someone throwing 50 to
100 grand in and going let's see this is
people going oh we'll pay you a proper
purse we'll make sure you yeah
it's becoming real and jj versus jake is
going to be massive so that would be on
a on a platform like they'd have to put
it on sky or disorder how does that map
out though because
you know we sort of skipped over the
fact that obviously jake is next
fighting looks like tommy fury right
that's the potential to be come back
down to earth it's a banana skin yeah
yeah because
every single person jake's fault he's
knocked out
and tommy's skill level
is by a mile higher than anything
uh jake's been in there with in his
actual competitive fight i know he's
sparred high level guys higher level
than tommy even
but this is a massive jump up is also a
big difference between sparring and
fighting as most people yeah it is a
real potential to set him back into a
youtuber fight right because this is his
first boxer and if he doesn't win
where do you go from there because tommy
is kind of the lowest level opponent he
can fight while being at a similar age
similar way and actually having some
clout yeah a reasonable amount of
relevance something that is a legitimate
name and a test and obviously because
the the fury name is there yeah that the
fury yeah the fury thing is going to
help fury massively yeah and we've seen
last time like john fury did most of the
selling
i love that i mean uh you know i hope he
brings up more 80s tv shows i hope he
calls jj a cat weasel i hope i hope
john's very much involved do you know
what i mean he has to be john like
because tommy isn't a good talker right
you know what i mean he's he's not a
good talker you know obviously he's
married to a really successful
entrepreneur so i imagine he doesn't
need to do a lot of his talking she does
a lot of the talking
uh for him those two go to dubai
together i'm sure they take each other's
pictures you know that that's a great
lifestyle is that the lifestyle of a
boxer brian someone who flies to dubai
and goes yeah i'll be your instagram
boyfriend for the weekend is that a man
who's taking boxing seriously i think he
is do you i i but i think he's just in a
weird place like sure he's stuck between
these two worlds he's fallen on his feet
he's got a girlfriend who's you know
this beautiful
entrepreneur who 25 she's created extra
hours in the day women
are obsessed with her right i mean like
they're constantly following every move
and that by
why but by proxy he then becomes like
the talk and boyfriend right and the one
that because she endorses him therefore
you should like him well if she's dating
him he must be a good yeah like he he
he's kind of like
an accessory to her life sure you know
like i thought he meant it's like murder
or something no like um
he's now part of the whole
kardashian style show that she's
creating right and and the love island
that sort of that machine is created
where people just come out and they get
onto the conveyor belt he's on that
conveyor belt i think he's a little bit
he doesn't know if he wants to be though
that's what i'm saying he's a bit
reluctant have you seen the clip of
tyson fury putting him to bed after the
the last fight the bit where it's post
fighting he basically goes uh yeah yeah
let's let's get in the bar or the club
or whatever and he's like no no you
should go home you should go home with
your woman
he was right wasn't he yeah why
because he didn't impress that night and
you like i'm a bit i get this like i get
this elite
uh athlete mentality sometimes of you
need to have a self-imposed
period of
things aren't happy i'm not happy right
now or i'm not like there was a moment
where tommy comes back into the dressing
room and tyson is the first person who
greets him after the fight because tommy
was on the undercard
and and tyson goes well you nearly got
him out of there yeah you know and let's
make no mistake about it like the guy
tommy was fighting wasn't a good fighter
no um he was
his fundamentals weren't there and he
could barely throw a good jab okay
this guy had a ten in one record and the
way they were selling them was look we
know we've had a load of bums in the
past but this guy's got ten and one
record but when you look at his ten and
one record
it's not legitimate in the way that you
would want it to be everyone he's fought
is from poland and i've just got a hunch
that all of those people just trust me
on this aren't that good right right and
i'm judging by the fact that he is
visibly bad and yet he's beaten these 10
guys right just a hunch not that good
maybe he didn't turn up on the big stage
maybe maybe that's so tommy showed more
natural like boxing technique has he
really he has little movements that he
does where you're like okay jake
wouldn't necessarily do that and these
are things that when you've been in a
boxing gym
from the age of five to 10 years old
he's picked up a lot of stuff that jake
hasn't had that time to do so
but the question is is is he does he hit
as hard as jake can he take a punch the
way jake can and and it seemed like he
coped that well with with some of those
blows he took last time well he's been
caught a lot by this big right hand that
people have thrown at him and if jake's
big right hand lands it's probably game
over because he has legit power yeah
he's got enough power to put you to
sleep right proper boxes to sleep it's
just whether or not you can land on a
proper boxer right and that's going to
be what determines
the fight because tommy is obviously
going to be getting told by
his dad by his brother here's how you
avoid the big right hand they know how
to do that
but
in the heat of the moment
people revert the type a lot of the time
and it's whether or not he can
stay on his game and whether or not
can can uh can line it up can can set it
up properly because sure against tyron
woodley
it wasn't a good performance from jake
when i look at when i look at the way he
was fighting gibbel
and gabo all over you
doesn't let you breathe and he was on
the back foot popping that jab out
timing him coming in
that was jake's most impressive
performance so what about if what about
the idea that jake wasn't all that
thrilled to be fighting tyrone woodley
again and therefore he was just like
let's just get this out of the way
i don't think so because the only thing
is after both fights with woodley jake
has complained about not feeling 100
saying his legs felt like jelly and
i don't know what's going on there
because the fundamentals
weren't as good as what i thought they
would be at this point um and and look
sometimes like the the crowd must get to
you um but i'm interested to see
tommy is such a good test for jake you
know what i mean he's yours yeah they
both really need it
and i actually think that there's more
riding on this for tommy personally
then jake obviously financially it's a
setback for jake but for jake you fought
a real boxer that everyone's been
banging on sit down to step up i don't
think jake is going to be finished by
tommy i don't see that kind of
devastating power but he could be
schooled he may eat him i think no
matter what happens with uh tommy and
jake jake goes on that path towards
fighting jj it's the other side with jj
where you go okay how does he map that
out to
prove publicly that he's the same level
as jake or at least is up there because
allegedly it's alex wassabi next right
or it could be dylan dannis if he beats
someone like dylan dennis does that that
mean he can mango all right i'll step up
to jake or like does he need a few
fights under his belt to sort of
legitimize this i weirdly think alex
wassabi is a harder fight than dylan
dennis
after after watching them flip it out
first
now go on well dylan dennis
i think is a very bad boxer okay
and he is he a good fighter
uh he's he's a good jiu jitsu guy but
then he also just got tapped out by some
chocolatier outside of a bar we've all
been there the bones are we've all had a
few too many there was a part-time
bouncer he wasn't even a full-time
bouncer he was part-time bouncer
part-time chocolatier put the two
together struggled right on the floor
just brute forced him just say
say toblerone yeah and um but dylan has
name value the fact that he's trained
with conor mcgregor and all the rest of
it but but he's just a little troll who
this guy hasn't fought in a long time
and when he did he he didn't look good
is he more of a social media star now
he's headed that way right but but
without being anything on social media
even i i kind of just think he's just
[__] his entire career that he could
have had right he could have really
piggybacked off the conor mcgregor thing
and instead
he's just become a bit of a joke whereas
alex wasabi is actually really quite a
fit kid can can run around the ring can
get you to
chase after him he he
he's got to try and pick jj apart a
little bit like land the job keep moving
jab moved sorry i just don't see how
jj doesn't wipe the floor with this and
that's part i guess that's part of the
problem for jj isn't it like it's a
lose-lose yes it's not a great fight for
him to come back there in that sense
because
he's a he's a tricky little [__] alex
wassabi in terms of he's fit and he is
going to be on his bike so you're going
to have to chase him down
what i want to see from jj in that is
not the lunging in and the wild swinging
that we've seen in logan paul one and
two like i didn't think that there was a
lot of
traditional boxing skills showing in
that i think bro he was a brawler and he
showed that he was game as [__] and he
had a good heart on him and that he
could bang
that's all good and at that level of
youtube that we were at then that was
enough it also brought people into it
because people didn't want to go and
they didn't want to go oh you know this
is a great level of boxing we're seeing
here they just wanted to see fighting
like they wanted
yeah and i think
with logan fighting mayweather ensured
that he had a lot more boxing technique
by that point than when he fought jj
the level is going up and jj needs to
prove that he has been training he has
been evolving because
if you come with that game plan against
you know the same game plan that you had
against logan and we see the same thing
of lunging in against alex wassabi
absolutely that might be alex wassabi
because jj hits hard right jake
but jake has fought people who do that
and more and he's proven by knocking
them out cold that he can time you
coming in like he did nate robinson and
and destroy you so jake jj
and i've seen him fight better than that
that was the thing is i've seen him i've
seen him spar um
they
and who's no no slouch yeah he's very
good and jj dropped him and showed a lot
more boxing technique in that so he
can't do it but i think it was look that
was the game plan for logan and logan
clearly didn't like that yeah and it
worked but
we need more now and and and against the
wasabi who is going to be on his bike
it's going to be interesting because we
nee we're needing to see a huge jump in
skill here and that's that's where the
pressure's on for jj's it's a guy who is
expected to beat he's piled the pressure
on himself by saying i will destroy the
sky this is a guy who just beaten his
brother handedly so there's a little bit
of family pride there i'm excited
because
this is also a massive payday
opportunity for jj in the long run
like jake paul versus ksi
is one of the biggest fights of this
decade financially i know interest wise
interest rates that's why that's nice
and this is going to be a [__] huge
fight eyeballs should make more money
they're underpaid i'm i'm excited for
the fight in that sense and i think at
the end of august when ksi and jake paul
have both thought we'll have a better
idea because let's say
jj comes out looking far more skilled
which i do expect which would also hope
he is because i i also think and let's
be honest here jj probably wouldn't have
set up this path for himself he had a
very comfortable life elsewhere you know
he's obviously doing the music he's got
the sidemen thing going which is going
really well for them for the music the
boxes we're bringing i think the main
aspect is he could have just gone you
know what i'm in a whole other life now
i thought he would yeah and if he didn't
want this and he didn't think he was
capable he wouldn't be doing this and
that's where the curiosity comes
i like the ego of it as well because
he's piling the pressure on himself and
look at that body man like the guy is in
great shape yeah you know he's he's
arguably in better shape than jake to
look at to look at 100 maybe they're
disco muscles but you know
100 years and i know he trains hard
because obviously leon's training him
and we know that [__] guys right really
he's still got leon just beasts people
yeah let's say jake
doesn't beat tommy
it immediately gives ksi so much more to
pile the pressure on and go you see
i could take i get that because to me
the natural stepping stone for
jj from
wasabi
is mcbroom
because mcbroom's a natural bad guy you
know like people in the uk would love to
hate him i mean he he embodies
everything that the uk dislikes about
american youtube right like he does the
family channel he did the a lot of
people
uh rightly or wrongly believe that
there's some form of exploitation of his
kids or his family status there
obviously there's some sort of backstory
which is still very mysterious that no
one really seems to know with him where
it's like okay what is his real business
relationship with his wife and business
relationship with other people but also
what's he like as a person because he's
very um contrived on camera like he
doesn't doesn't seem to be himself on
camera he seems to be the character of
austin mcbroom he's got his cool
demeanor but you can tell
he's not a rad dude
like he's not gib's more of like that
dog style of fighter he's not the pretty
boy sort of walking around obviously
good looking guy but he's not the pretty
boy sort of walking around with the swag
he fights hard exactly
and i'd expect him
i'd expect him to beat mcbroom like
relatively comfortable so this is the
thing is that
that's kind of the only unfortunate
thing right if you're wanting a natural
progression for jj right it's to fight
the winner of austin versus gabe but
gibbs is bro and yeah you guys a lot
right friends so that ain't gonna happen
but that would have been a really good
progression but mcbroom has some natural
talent and and that's that's one thing
that i've seen i'm not saying it's
enough to be gabe the thing with the the
gib fight and you know i might do a
breakdown where it's more specific but
here's the thing
the only way you beat gibb is if you hit
hard right if you hit hard you can keep
him off you yeah but if he does not
respect your power he comes inside yeah
exactly so it's just going to be all
over you so that's the only he's only
lost against jake paul arguably with
jake paul and i was i was actually took
a car journey the other day with the guy
who shot behind the scenes of all the
gibb stuff before the jake paul fight
and he said a lot of what gib ended up
doing in the ring wasn't the game plan
like he was he was disappointed that he
didn't execute the game plan so yeah
that's what i remember
i remember vidal and leon obviously
saying as much that they had they
deviated to suit what gabe wanted to do
right rather than what they thought was
the best option right and but he's sort
of changed a bit since then hasn't he
like benefited
exactly yeah so
before obviously it was it was just
mayhem and he's sort of walking to the
ring screaming my time over and over
again which i love that which is great
but the point is is
what
he was a madman and i think you just
have to edge you know turn that down a
little throw that energy and just
pinpoint it you know and
against taylor and everyone i think
aside from me
i don't know many was were picking
taylor because taylor had shown that he
was quite slick
but
because we we'd been in the gym filming
in west ham
yeah we'd seen gabe and gabe as
uh hard as nails i i heard one of the
other youtube boxers say something about
um
who's the kid he's in beta squad he
actually looked quite good in the on the
last oh yeah what was that kid's name
king kennedy
yeah can he can he look quite good yeah
kenny kenny's sort of got a bit of a
thing in this because better squad are
obviously they're they're the rivals to
um
to side man yeah in the uk so he might
have a bit of a stake in this or he
might he might be like a late uh you
know one of those runners that come from
i do think that there's potential there
but like the last kid who he thought the
fierce guy
just looked really good like he but he'd
had a lot of karate and all sorts
apparently what you can do against cry
he
he did like that was the problem was
those two were almost too legit and they
met each other they
both needed a prep fight so that people
go [__] hell he's good yeah so kenny
was talking about fighting game but but
and i remember kenny saying something
about gabby he said i think i could take
him because i'm not sure on his chin
and honestly this isn't you know i don't
care these these two guys fight would be
a great fight i'm sure because they're
both good but
gabe's chin is rock right like if you
look at it
he's the only person who fought jake
paul who didn't go to sleep
i would say the dead you but obviously
that was the first fight and they had
head guards on and all of that like if
the fight hadn't have been
stopped though no it but the point was
he took some great shots yeah and he
kept going and he kept going and i've
seen gabe and sparring as far vidal and
other people and obviously vidal you
know he looks after people but the point
is i've been very impressed with the
heart and the chin yeah
because every now and again vidal does
that thing where he'll slip you a little
something
just to remind you like yeah you're in
the [__] hands exactly yeah and
that's what you need as an amateur a
novice you know what i mean but but the
point i'm making is
if unless you hit hard you aren't
beating him at this level and that's why
i knew taylor was losing because he
didn't have enough beef behind his shots
give
give that's the thing is like even for
ksik it would be a hell of a test in my
opinion and that's probably why they
spawn together so much because it's it's
good for them but
i'm thinking they weren't for me
i'm thinking gabe beats mcbroom and
that's the problem is where does ksi go
next really it might be
a quicker jump to jake than
we think yeah just because there might
not be a route mapped there for jj and
that's what i was saying when we started
this like i don't know maybe there's
someone that comes out of nowhere and
you know they they fight on the lower on
the undercard and suddenly there's like
i've beaten him i want to take step up
yeah maybe or someone like that i think
it has to be an american i think it's
got to be you want to keep that atlantic
thing going you know once you go
internally in the uk i don't think the
interest is about coming back but logan
seems to want to go
it's hard when you fought mayweather he
i think he's got his eyes on
huge things he's he's wrestlemania yeah
he's mia
ironically of all of the performances so
far
i think logan against mayweather was the
best youtuber boxing performance oh yeah
100 yeah yeah no disrespect to jake
because he's had the more highlight reel
moments but
the the level of boxing ability he
showed there it was really something
also with mayweather's actual feedback
in the corner like the feedback that is
harder
exactly yeah but also mate so not only
where is corner going you need to do
this he was going i can't do this like
that's that's impressive and and that's
the the thing but i i don't know if
i think logan just wants to put on the
biggest shows possible whether that be
wrestling boxing anything you know he
understands the game in a different way
i think
he's if i was logging in
this is honest truth i'll be going for a
ufc fight because his his natural
athletic ability
and his background in wrestling i've
seen him sorry when you say do you mean
actual ufc absolutely going into the ufc
he's he's already had the uh heads up of
dana that he would consider it
i've seen him roll with uh paulo costa
the middleweight
coffee place and he looked a gr he
looked very good in that given
and i would literally have a gym set up
i'd have jiu-jitsu trainers kickboxing
trainers that have all of that because
he can afford all of this [__] now he's
buying pokemon cards for christ's sake
for millions of people
and i'd be going you know what i want to
be the guy who wrestled at wrestlemania
who fought floyd mayweather and fought
in the ufc and like
find the find a guy you know what i mean
to to do that with of his level and yeah
yeah he mentioned paddy like i don't
think they'd risk paddy in that way
because paddy's a bit of a money he's a
boy isn't he yeah he's a scouser he's
obviously he's got a bit of he's got a
bit of charisma about a bit more than a
bit of charisma but you know he's loved
by
england in general yeah he's our guy now
and the only thing is though paddy does
paddy got up to over 200 pounds recently
he fights at 155.
it's impressive 50. yeah but if that
becomes his thing but that's the thing
is after after meeting them both the the
size discrepancy isn't what you yeah
it's there but it isn't it isn't just
not think yeah yeah i remember meeting
paddy thinking you're a lightweight
you're quite a big guy it's interesting
but you know when logan gets up to like
you know logan walk around compared to
when he's in prep for a fight i've
hugged him both times
like
i remember him when he was doing the
little frenchman thing with the hat and
the thing
he was
vast like the guy was like you were
struggling to get your arms sort of
around
he's got that optimal
uh build like it's it's built to put
muscle so he he could make middleweight
and he yeah he's bigger than michael
bisping right you know he wasn't
middleweight champion so he has that
very
enviable
uh long leg small waist long arms
but a strong core right um and who
doesn't want that that no but like you
basically just described your perfect
woman you know but your you're basically
ideal to make the most out of yourself
at that weight class
so but anyway i'd go for that uh it just
depends really
first of all i think what it requires is
some seriously good commentators because
you're going to need people who can
unpack this now at this level we can't
just be going for and i think that's
what we learned last time you can't have
people coming in the rings and doing
like stupid little uh poems and stuff
like oh
no that was just painful
this is a different level now this is
jake paul this is ksi these guys are
millionaires these guys are the kind of
people who have teams around them now
this isn't an amateur operation anymore
it needs to be taken seriously this
needs now it's going on zone or b or
wherever you want to put it it's got to
look legit and i think this legitimizes
everything you know you know this is a
big the biggest step is coming in the
next year for youtube boxing i think
yeah i really dislike the way like let's
take for example the when when jake
fought gabe the way the commentators
were
looking down their noses right it's like
what
these guys are getting in the ring
they've got every right to get in the
ring give them that respect like people
die in the ring we've just lost someone
in i think with south africa in the last
week everyone would have seen the viral
clip of um the guy who took a shot and
then was punching thin air after did he
pass away he died yeah i mean that makes
sense but i mean that's also tragic so
it was internal bleeding on the brain
and obviously um
you know that that setup did not it
didn't look
the type of place where because
when when you take a shot to the head
like that and this is this has been put
in place in the uk because of this
happening you need ambulances on
[__] queue like everything needs to
be ready to go because
time is of the essence yeah because yeah
i mean it's the brain
i know that's common sense but like what
i'm what i mean is this like more so
than any other injury
you've got a finite amount of time and
and that that guy obviously they didn't
make it in time and that's the thing is
like it's very sad but that's why i get
frustrated when people look down their
nose at it and i and i get like some
fights are silly you know like and i and
i but but when you've got two people
who've trained hard taking it seriously
you've
you know jake versus gabe was that yeah
you've got to take you got to give it
some respect and not only that i think
you need people who are gonna gonna
bring the balance you can't it sort of
ruins the product a bit when you have
people who are commentating who are
looking down their nose at it because as
someone who's tuning in and is paying
money
you want to enjoy it you don't want to
be you don't have to take part in this
whole sort of oh look at these guys yeah
like that's a bit old hat now it's kind
of done to look down like if you listen
to this commentary of ksi versus logan 2
adam from sky it's live he doesn't do
that line but that's that's my title but
yeah he he has some respect for a real
guy i actually rate him as a boxing
commentator he's actually a legend of
the game but
he was completely out of his granddad
yeah and that just doesn't work it would
also be lovely to have someone like him
ringside to be able to do something but
just not be the main person yeah no but
not be not be the main person you know
i think it requires a bit of a change
and that's what i'm saying i'm not
saying it should be me i don't think it
should be me but i think definitely
someone like you should be involved i
also think like there's some really good
other people who are in the space on
youtube who understand the space what
about liam from uh shivers oh yeah um
yeah liam from one direction someone
actually messaged me quite a few people
i've had a lot of people wanted to talk
about this kid right first of all i'm
offended uh i'm a white guy and sure i
have
a uh like a boy bandish kind of look or
like at least i used to be i you know
you look like uh man bandy now like you
know when um take that came back yeah
sure like when they were dads yeah
you're right yeah sure um sorry again
upsetting but but okay a few people
message me and when you have liam from
one direction vibes now
i don't think that's true and i'm a
little bit upset by it i think in terms
of your self-awareness you're really
about the same yeah right there's a
quote i want to bring out from this guy
really well one of them got him up
against the wall and he said either take
those hands off me or you or you won't
be using them again or something like
that
or you might never use them again yeah
it's also that it was the the deadpan
weight delivers that is and you see
logan go
yeah
oh you're serious yeah yeah liam takes
himself
incredibly seriously and and obviously i
think that comes from being in a boy
band since a very young age where a lot
of people will be around them who are
going yeah well yeah yes sir no sir
three bags full sir like no one can
always he's ended up the way he is
without having a serious level of ass
kissing right yeah to make him believe
he is great at what he does right and
let's face it like you know i think a
lot of people are very talented
musicians but i i i don't know if he's
but he's not more talented yeah he's not
one of them like if
there's a reason why you're going in one
direction yeah you you you have some
talent you can kind of sing yeah and
simon cowgle's not quite strong enough
to go on his own though right so he's no
will young so what we'll do
is we'll get a load of other pretty boys
put them together who can all kind of
sing like seven eight out of ten singers
but together
girls i love them right and that's why
it looks after this podcast
all the girls are on twitter
morning
asking them questions or whatever i
think logan was getting a bit of stick
for it but
logan got sick for asking i don't know
it's all the same [__] to me isn't it
but the point is people don't seem to
understand but by the way podcasts
podcast people think podcasts work this
way i watch your podcast your podcast
should be what i want it to be no it's
the other way our podcast is what we
want it to be it's your choice whether
you watch it or not it's not our thing
to please you it's your thing to be
pleased by us or don't we'll just put it
off so yourself exactly yes it you don't
you know if you walked into if you
walked into uh curries and went yes i'd
like some trainers please they go we
don't do trainers here you don't go well
that's not customer service is it
they're trying to blame logan for their
little pretty boy coming off like a
[__] that's his fault the words came
out of his mouth are you talking about
logan or liam now liam right good
logan's pretty tough logan's very pretty
okay so the point is the guy was coming
out with uttar nonsense yeah i kind of
want to find it um i've actually spoken
to this guy once before as it happens on
a poke stars tournament uh we ended up
in a chat room together oh really what
kind of things did you chat about well
it was just weird because um
it was a celebrity tournament so i was
there why are we doing it i wonder who's
gonna
it'd be in my group and it was just
literally me and liam
and i was like he just pops up and i'm
like is that the guy from one direction
like did you did you instantly recognize
it oh yeah right yeah because you know
it you know he [__] cheryl cole didn't
he had it
baby
uh what we had weirdly cheryl cole met
him when he was very very young
oh and she [__] it but she was like
and
she was like a cougar and he gave her a
wink and it turns out that stuck with
her and she ended up shagging him and
having a kid with him lit up his word
like nobody else but the point is um the
way that she did her hair got him
overwhelmed i should have literally just
said i know you love geordies all right
all right son wanna just want a piece of
this ah right um you would have you
would have done some sort of uh
masturbation mutual masturbation thing
on this call i mean if you transferred
the cash close enough
so yeah the guy the guy clearly has
lived a sheltered life where and this is
the thing he's part of a boy band who
was selected because they aren't
talented enough to be on their own
they're all built around and and they've
been completely and utterly manufactured
to
uh make their lives easier so a lot of
the songwriting a lot of the you know
tunes and all of that they're not a band
they're not a band they're not the
beaters they're not they're they're a
group right and they're a group that has
the collectives you know and when he
goes on on the podcast like i've written
some of the biggest selling songs ever
it's like you're not paul mccartney but
this is yeah that's the point numbers
yeah at this manufactured level i mean
nothing i mean nothing yeah right the
most viewed youtube videos don't make
them the best the most played songs are
ed sheeran right enough said he's real
like ed sheeran music is very good i
don't understand what you're interested
in the nazis it didn't make them good no
am i comparing one direction to the
nazis i think i just did i think in a
way but i also think what you need to go
down the route a lot of people wanted
hitler
doesn't make him good
beautiful
that's what makes you beautiful
that's the point though is like that may
be one of the worst songs ever no
because but it's so catchy yeah that's a
little girl
you ever seen that little girl who sings
it the one who's like you're insecure
weirdly you've got a similar
when you're a producer now you want
your music
to be heard by the masses you want
people to love the tunes
and you work with who can afford that if
a record company has someone there that
they know they throw money behind and
they make money out of they're going to
get you the best producers how on earth
did liam payne end up in a room with
pharrell williams it ain't an accident
pharrell wasn't like you know how i'd
love to work with leo liam payne no
that's not what happened no he wanted
harry styles and they went we've got the
little version no but the point is is
even he said i [__] the bed because i
wasn't [__] good enough and i knew
and that should have been his first
thing i knew i wasn't good enough so
when liam quickly basically was like
yeah sure if i care sorry you're like
you're not in the real world son you
you've had people tell you you're a
great musician
and now you think you're some sort of
tough guy do you think he's tough or
jesus oh he rapes himself yeah yeah he
because i feel like harry like you know
harry styles he's my favorite one like
he sort of he comes across as like quite
um sort of girly you know just sort of
oh we're just having a bit of fun with
it aren't we like oh our boyfriend's
broken up with us and god well what men
just
they're just a riddle to be solved you
know that's a song men are just a riddle
to be sold
this is how you write songs this is
literally how you so this is the thing
though just just to be clear one
direction broke up because and i quote
they didn't want to exhaust their van
fan base
we broke up because we thought it was a
little too much for you all right you
could have gotten tired by this but he
literally said like he wanted to beat
the [__] out of some of them and that
sort of thing and i think i think he
could
i think i think liam liam payne compared
to and i'll read their names
zayn okay zayn zayn is very low body fat
i think he could probably be
hiding away from jake paul as jake paul
banged on his hotel room and asked them
to get out yeah that was weird though i
would be a little bit intimidated by you
know jake's again he's got a bit of the
dog in him no but similar
it's the fact that zayn could be heard
on the other side of the dog just [__]
off just leave me alone i mean to be
fair you know if you're zane as well i
don't think zayn wants any of this stuff
i don't think zayn's the kind of guy who
wants that zayn is obviously chugging
that model and just living the life and
he it was entertaining
it was but it was also sad to see
someone who was
you know so out of touch with reality
and but it also gave a great window
because
most celebrities are around about that
level of delusion
it's just he was feeling himself and it
came out and it came out in a big way
the fact that he said he could fight ksi
like
k side rip his [__] head off within
about
30 to 60 seconds it would be it will be
over and it will be in brutal fashion
but i suppose liam's main response to
that would be and i quote
live life for the moment because
everything else
is uncertain
if you want to do something go for it
you've got nothing to lose these are
quotes that are attributed to this man
all right i don't understand what like
he actually also said the words i'm a
bit old-fashioned that's a quote that's
attributed to this guy the the [__] that
comes out of these people's mouths and
we have to pretend like these people are
smart
i can't really cook but the first dish i
ever made was my girlfriend
that's a quote on a quote page i've got
nothing against him per se like i don't
really give a [__] either way obviously
but
he's a knob did he deserve to have that
level of backlash you know because he
was a bit of a knob on a podcast once
and we sort of saw a bit behind the
curtain did he really deserve that i
don't think there's a publication
i think there's been a lot of people
like you know our types podcast guys
you're a bit smarter than you know we
sort of went
yeah i mean he's been exposed doesn't he
you know he's been exposed for being a
delusional [__] it doesn't mean that he
is the worst person in the world no i
think and i'm not saying that that'll go
on my headstone i think but like yeah i
get your point he's he's he's a little
bit of a knob you know what i mean but
like life has a way when you're up your
own house of exposing that and making
sure
you get slapped a little bit and walking
up from it you know what i mean and
maybe
you'd hope
he'd have the humility to realize oh
[__] i do sound ridiculous when asked
what foodie would be he said i'd be a
birthday cake anyone who thinks they're
a birthday cake definitely has delusions
of grandeur so he admitted that a couple
of them crossed swords and they were
[__] the same [__] in the same room
don't know but dangerous territory
admitted that one of them [__] the
same girl and if you're that girl up
kind of well done but also kind of calm
down you know what i mean ironically she
was taking dick from multiple directions
literally yeah imagine they spit roasted
or though i don't need to imagine that
brian that was uh lizzo
has reacted to liam payne's interview
and said he was not the front man of one
direction oh thank god lizzo said that
glad lizzles got involved so he
basically went yeah the simon loved me
and just said i'll grab a few other guys
that's not true though is it because i
mean it just isn't true i think simon
would have sold it to him like that but
you were dead on probably the first
second all of them didn't even suck in
his dick all right would you suck simon
cowell off if it meant you got millions
of pounds i think a lot of them would
and you know what if that was my son
i'll just say look mate you know get in
there we're not going to get a mansion
without getting a little comment on it
you you're michael jackson well take
pictures of my ass no no you michael
jackson in the sense that a lot of those
parents went oh yeah off you go i guess
this is really healthy for young women
out there who are um kind of in their
head they create an illusion of what
these these boyfriend characters are
right and then they meet regular dudes
and they're like well it's a [__] let
down isn't it right you need to know
most men are empty vessels 100 like
they're they're men on a mission and
usually that mission is very selfish
right and and what you've just found out
is is that little boyfriend figure in
your mind that you created also a dick
sure so none of you are safe from
[__] they're all [__] even the
ones with nice
voices and pretty faces also [__]
i'm a married man so
this isn't about you right it's all
about you i thought you'd been passive
aggressive again
um so i think that this is weirdly a
good thing to see someone outed in that
way right to lower women's expectations
of what men should be able to achieve if
there's one thing i'm about it's
lowering the expectations of women right
and you i think you've made that your
life's mission absolutely right it's
very much sort of a a long journey um do
you think this is mixed with a bit of
self-discovery okay do you think you
have like do you think all men have
hidden depths like what i'm saying is
you know in modern society i think in
many ways like
men will get with a woman and they will
be um
they won't have that level to them yet
like they won't have discovered it and a
good partner will bring that out of you
but there are a lot of people who are
not compatible but they just go we'll
just stay together and what the man does
is he just closes off
and just sort of ordered yeah and but
that's also part for the rest of his
life but if you do autopilot for too
long you get stuck in autopilot and you
ain't coming back from autopilot do you
know what i mean by that so you
basically just go yep just bring this
baby into land
i think that should we have another bbq
this weekend i think i'll go out and do
the lawn like lots of little things like
that where you just basically come up
with hours and hours to spend away from
your wife you know
and then the women get into that thing
where they basically go
everything's funny to them somewhere
reason isn't that isn't that cute they
get really into the kids
and ultimately you're living a pretty
depressing life where you can actually
could have been pretty happy with each
other a lot of people when they hit
their 30s they start thinking you know
what
i just want a bit of comfort i want my
30s i want a bit of comfort i want to
feel like i'm with a secure relationship
and maybe mortgage and life is settled
you know what i mean and i think
because of that that often means people
end up going into a comfort zone
and that's the there's a difference
isn't there there's a difference between
being comfortable and stretching off
right and having a comfortable life
but some people just literally just
switch off because life is hard you know
what i mean right and i think a lot of
people just think you know what can i be
asked with this [__] i agree i sometimes
have felt so that's why i feel like
that's like low level pressure
they stay in relationships that maybe
aren't good for them because they're
like you know what the hassle of getting
out of this starting over on my own and
all of that sort of stuff
ah [__] it i'll just play it easy
there's a theory that i remember hearing
about where it's like
for women they're always looking for
that that guy they've got a thing in
their head that they're looking for and
they're trying to get as close as they
can what do you think that is whereas
men right
men apparently are a lot more like they
wake up one day and decide they're ready
for commitment and then it's the next
girl that they meet
really
that that's a it's obviously it's it's
not true
but but there's there's a lot of people
who believe that that's kind of how it
works do you think that's a hormone
thing or do you think it's like a
biological thing where you're basically
like when you hit a certain age your
body basically goes well we need to get
this seat out there somewhere time to
commit i've definitely been around quite
a few men who i felt like
committed because it felt like the right
time to not necessarily the right person
absolutely i mean we all know someone
whereas with women you're talking more
generally here you're not saying all
women are like this you're definitely
not saying
you're not saying lgbt women like this
we're not saying that a few people are
like this can we not can we no we need
to do the caveats i think women are
similar in that sometimes that they are
just prioritizing commitment of any sort
i think women care more about who it's
with than men generally really yeah but
in the long run it will damage you if
you get with the wrong person
it damages your whole life yeah and i've
i've seen that happen before where women
have been
in a relationship and it's time to get
serious and then they have that that
moment of like [__] hell with this
guy right yeah but ultimately they're
too far down the road already well some
of them sometimes they back out you know
what i mean i think men are men are
better are just solemnly going down with
the ship
you know what i can understand i think
women have a bit more um
women often on a daily basis ask
themselves am i happy
and that is a real problem for men
because we're a lot better at just going
into cruise control and sort of living
out [__]
i feel like women have more uh standards
for their life this isn't a criticism
this is just how i say
right okay
in many respects yeah you're not saying
that's true in every way i think women
are more switched on than men alive
that's also what i think society is sort
of building people towards now so they
it's not necessarily that's inherent to
men it's that what the current setup we
have kind of is moving people in that
direction but it is genetically as well
i do i just think women live more in
their heads than men do men men are
better at switching off and going
through the motions and whereas
and and that's why men often feel hustle
when what's happened well men want an
easy life right do women not also um
women care more about the details maybe
yeah and and what their friends are
doing and how how that reflects on how
they then feel them paying more
attention to what their friends fellows
are giving them and and how where am i
happy is this enough am i getting enough
of my and and that's where the questions
start coming towards the mind of why
haven't you done this for me lately do
you love me or is this right you know
all of those kind of things you find
yourself a resilient woman and that's
why men often are like oh god
okay we'll do this because i want to
keep up appearances i want to keep keep
making her feel okay because i'm trying
to book a whole day to inappropriately
because ultimately
i don't want the hassle of being pulled
up on things i mean questioned about
things is that not a stereotype though
that i think a lot of people everything
i'm saying is a stereotype okay i'm glad
you know okay yeah what i'm saying is
like this is this is a rule but there
are many exceptions to the rule but i do
think that what i'm saying
unfortunately go through a lot okay so
but that doesn't mean that men or women
are destined to do them it's just that
these things play out quite a lot
because when people are in a long-term
relationship women are less comfortable
than men are men men get their feet
under the table and like right sorted
out sure
did everything did the wedding yada yada
we got the kids blah blah blah and now i
just want to go into cruise control
whereas women are still wanting the
fairy tale to continue whereas for a lot
of men it's like i've done that now i
guess you share some qualities with
women in that sense that you you're
never really happy you're quite restless
you're always questioning things that's
because i was raised by a woman though
right and because a single mom
essentially oh yeah so you have similar
to me you have a lot of feminine
qualities which manifest in quite a
masculine way yeah i mean i i always
feel like my part of my brain is
feminine uh because of being around a
loving woman all the time right and
understanding that women do think a bit
more about that so therefore it's
probably left a mark on me to think more
about is this enough
am i happy is this what i want you are
quite that's that's a lot of
i feel like that's you like it leaves
you a bit restless though if that makes
sense of course yeah but that's i mean
that's interesting to unpack but at the
same time i also want to see you happy
so what makes you happy
and that's where the the masculine side
of it comes in of wanting comfort of
wanting rocket league
i'm also aware that like you have to
play the game and you have to kind of
be a bit on both sides and do
i get enough for each other to make to
make that last don't you i i really uh
and i think you're like it's fine i
deeped it for a little while after yeah
i did and that sort of apologized it's a
podcast phrase i picked up uh so if you
want to make it sound like you're
very thoughtful about something and that
you've really put some time and effort
into it you go
you know if you really deep it okay and
then you drop a profound thought go for
it i did some reflecting on amber heard
and johnny depp oh we've been asked to
cover this because obviously now there's
been a a a verdict and johnny
essentially won can i can i give you my
teacher no she was lying right i get
that who would have thought it on a
surface level we've done we've done the
whole lying thing right
but i was quite interested afterwards
when i was thinking about
everyone has sort of invested in one
side or the other
and kind of i
i guess to me i was sitting there
thinking
why have we done that like why is there
such investment in johnny
and amber
i think it's because it's a very rare
case because
generally speaking this is the first
time where we've seen a high profile
case where the man has gone the attack
after being the accused
but so he was the accused in the uk and
he was actually found guilty of um quite
a few things in england and then he took
it to america
and i think he got her on the stand and
that was a major difference and that's
what i'm thinking here is i think
justice in america is a little bit
different to justice in england and i
think this was just this this was trial
by us she killed his career with the
accusations this is trial by the public
this is a pr and this is the most
important thing in reality to a career
is whether we want to see his movies
again and if we feel like he is this
evil monster that she painted them out
to be harvey weinstein we do not want to
go and yeah harvey weinstein bill cosby
powerful men in the past have abused
their power right which does happen not
denying that but obviously um
you know this was more revealing because
we got to see her on the stand and we
got to see
what an obvious liar she really is no
and i get that and but um i guess what
i'm saying is like people can get a bit
bogged down in the weeds of it part of
me didn't i don't still understand why
there is this need to invest in one side
or the other do you know what i mean
well i think men and women both feel
attachment of this because women
obviously have been victims a lot of
women a staggering amount of women have
been victims of um abuse or coercion or
whatever you want in one way or another
right and um
and men also
feel like
because when women talk about this
publicly
they use the phrase men which obviously
it doesn't mean all men
but when men read those things they take
it a bit to heart and therefore
they feel like well it isn't all men and
i think men out there wanted to show
that you know sometimes
the accusations will be false right
there is no 362 in this hotel and kind
of the point i made in that podcast
which was ironically um clipped up out
of context deliberately misinterpreted
um and and therefore it's that beautiful
um way that
online works where you go i'm gonna
deliberately misinterpret what he said
i'm then gonna use fake outrage
and be a social justice warrior against
this person even when i know the real
point he's making is a valid one but
that doesn't help me further my own
career all my own uh status is yeah so
that if i'm seen as the guy who's
bashing true geordie i've then got
something to gain from this also because
i think what comes with true geordi is
you're shorthand for men you're kind of
an easy quite masculine target now the
other aspect is like you know when
you're watching that clip back did you
sort of go oh i could have you know what
yeah actually i probably could have said
that a bit better i would have made that
of course but
at the same time the but i i know what
you meant but everyone knew what i meant
well clearly not brandon no there's a
lot of very angry people because people
deliberately misinterpret the broad
point so so for example
uh some of the examples of celebrities
are used one of them was guilty of
something right maybe two of them yeah
what are different reasons yeah but
which was stupid of me but i think i
mentioned chris brown and uh cristiano
ronaldo and uh conor mcgregor mcgregor
right they were a few but the point is
is
the list of famous men who have been
accused of wrongdoing towards women is
insanely big
it is it is
from neil degrasse tyson to nev neve off
of
catfish that was proven to be untrue by
the way that was that was actually
completely white the point is regardless
is is
chris brown obviously people thought i
was on about rihanna when i wasn't on
about the rihanna i think it was another
accusation about a month ago chris brown
had an accusation that was oh actually i
think he took that to court didn't he
yeah i think so but yeah and and
you had neymar cristiano ronaldo like so
many superstars and the point i was
making wasn't that they're honestly not
a great
the point i'm making isn't that whether
they're guilty or not no right because
i'm sure some of them are guilty i
obviously prove it
powerful men have abused power before
weinstein and bill cosby you know to the
worst degrees obviously many of them but
all my point is is is symbol
johnny depp was proven to be
innocent in my opinion right but only of
defamation only of defamation but but
i've seen more than enough to think
this was a toxic relationship where if
anyone was more abusive it was her right
yet she was the one slinging the [__]
and so that's why
my point was only that when you look
into their financial
situation and you see johnny depp worth
500 million amber heard worth a couple
of million and the level of reward that
could have been there for her to bounce
a career off of the back of being a
married to him but also being a victim
of his and therefore becoming
uh somewhat of a a person that hollywood
has to gather around and help out and
boost her career to take the victim um
position in that triangle the drama
triangle and and more importantly like i
personally have had a babysitter when i
was a kid try and touch me right and and
and that sort of thing so i'm not
marginalizing overall victims because i
know
um
not just women right but people yeah can
be victims of men who are in a position
of power as that babysitter was with me
right okay now luckily that you know
didn't go the way it could have done but
it was terrifying you know i mean it was
a scary moment in my life when i was a
kid i was about eight years old so to so
to that extent what you're saying is you
understand or you feel that you can
relate to the
their their position as well absolutely
i've interviewed a woman who was
kidnapped for nine months at 14 years
old and it was one of the most
if not the most powerful interview of my
entire life right so emotionally
i i connect as best as i'm a man can
with people who've been uh victims on a
general level and as i said in the
podcast which obviously didn't make it
to social media uh they should do that
really i think when people do the
clipping they should be able to put
multiple bits together what people tend
to do is take one piece
don't click me out of context and just
watch the entire podcast the point is we
should probably call the podcast that
yeah the point is is general people
in everyday life who
have issues like that and make
accusations
i generally think probably 99.999
are telling the truth and maybe there's
one crazy person in there who may not be
for example i think to act like no one
would ever lie
is
silly right right right and and i as
amber heard proved how much she lied
whether it be about donating the money
or all the accusations towards johnny
which had such little proof and his
accusations to her had such big proof
but also how people had experienced the
complete opposite of what she'd
experienced so absolutely so all i'm
saying is
when there's such a huge reward
as johnny had above his head and as all
of these male celebrities have above
their head
as as she proved i'm not saying
something that hasn't been proven
sometimes someone can lie in order to
secure the bag and i just think that
the fact that so many huge celebrities
have been accused of these things it
makes me think that the likelihood is is
that some of them have also been falsely
accused absolutely and i think but but
i'm not saying that that's definite i'm
saying it could have happened right and
therefore
logically
there are people out there who would
stab someone in the chest for a million
pound there are there are men and women
who would do that this isn't a sexism
thing this is just an opportunist thing
people are opportunists in life and to
deny that and to ignore that that's even
a possibility it's burying your head in
the sand and nothing like this that
someone wouldn't lie about someone in
order to secure a 10 million pound
payout or whatever and change your life
when people burgle people people do
things that offer minimal amount of
money so then to say that they wouldn't
wrong philly
and lie about someone to secure millions
of pounds
as as a potential just to even
acknowledge that it could happen and
to then say i'm a victim blamer just for
even saying hey this is possible guess
uh
amber heard did that maybe someone else
might have done it before to even call
me a victim blamer just for suggesting
that that is a possibility
is insane right it is insane and i get
that because i'm not saying
every celebrity who's ever been accused
is innocent that would be mental that is
not i don't
when people try and take you out of
context and they deliberately
misinterpret you so that they can put
themselves on a pedestal as the hero
who is bashing you because you're such a
bad guy and they're trying to cancel you
you i don't respond to it because
they're only making themselves look
stupid everyone who knows me
knows that that's not what i am or that
what you're saying no yeah because
because i ask everyone with common sense
out there knows that but some people
just don't like and
like the fact that i've made a success
out of my life but you know what here's
the sad bit for those [__] you know if
they you do manage to somehow cancel me
you get rid of me your life's still [__]
you're not you don't get the chair you
don't get to come and live here and be
the podcaster
you don't get to take away everything
i've built for my hard work when you
kill the king doesn't don't you then
right you don't you still you don't get
all the food in my fridge you don't get
my tv you don't get every year that's a
lot of faith
so destroying me
as much as that might feel good in that
moment
you're not going to be happy but i okay
but that's kind of what i understood
from um that was
i realized there are many different
angles that people come at this uh case
from
and i think you were coming at it from
one angle and your focus was um
very more more male focused than female
focus naturally you're a man the reason
i brought the i had a babysitter when i
was eight years old rubbing on his
crotch in front of me that's horrible
and and wanting to [__] right
so
in it ain't like i'm
unable to imagine how a woman would feel
in that situation because i was a child
yeah in that situation so for them to
have a go at me and i have no shame in
admitting that and i don't think anyone
why would you yeah um for them to be
like this guy
like it's like well actually i do have
experience in that but you didn't you
didn't know that because you know why
you looked at me and thought big man
with tattoos couldn't possibly ever have
been a victim of sexual abuse sure or
anything like that because they see you
now not exactly right and that's why
people attack me as well because they
look at me and think manly man who is
suggesting that a woman could lie purely
because a woman has lied and that's been
proven and we've seen that happen i mean
it has been played out literally we've
seen that she's lied about all sorts of
things but that doesn't mean all women
are liars i'm just saying it could have
happened before but for them to just
take one look at me and bash me
i've had this my whole life and i'm
quite fed up with it now like i know i
might look gammon or whatever right or
whatever they say already like a brexit
looking [__] or whatever just because
i'm you know tattooed and did you forget
it but
i'm kind of fed up with it you know what
i mean
i'm bored with it that's why i don't
respond publicly on all the tweets and
all that i just can't you don't know you
don't know so [__] off you know what i
mean yeah they use a bias against me
because i've said something dumb about
football and that's kind of what i'm
saying or something that they didn't
like on or they've seen the rant videos
from years ago and they think that
that's who this guy is and they think
they know you and this is the smart
thing i think amber heard did or amber
hood's people did they made it about
women right and that's why they keep
saying and that's what i said that's why
they keep saying this verdict the set
women but no it hasn't you've set women
back right you know why you set women
back because you lied right you lied
yeah and all of the other women out
there who are telling the truth are now
going to be looked at with skepticism
because of what you did so don't blame
me for what amber heard did that's what
i found amber heard lied so that's i
didn't like it right
you're telling what you believe to be
the truth there and and what you're
saying how you see it
that's what pisses me off
because what they don't realize is spin
campaign is working on them because by
me even mentioning that other women may
have done that before
they're attacking me but it's because of
amber heard that we're having to
acknowledge that it's because of people
like her
scumbags
who want to take down a guy who's worked
very hard for his whole career because
it's better than her going back to her
[__] life right but
and then there's the johnny side of the
spin machine where i think that's that's
what johnny
it felt to me the more i looked at it
the more like the pr people around
johnny had gone we need to get a hold on
this because we need your career to keep
going basically i don't think so i don't
think that i think it was it was do or
die it was your career is [__] you
need to challenge her with everything we
have and have this out in court in front
of the world because then they'll save
right once she's on the stand he knew
her and he knew
like liam
likely in pain put a microphone in front
of him i bet you're all those one
direction lads in that band are like
thrilled no but i bet they're like
now you will see one yeah no yeah zayn
probably went now
yeah yeah and similarly the minute she
was on the stand and started with the
tears about the most ridiculous of
things in overwrapping and showing that
she was overacting because she was
desperately in trouble and trying to
sell everything that was [__] johnny
depp would have sat back when i knew
this was going to happen because i know
her i'm bored of something happening in
one person's life
like a celebrity or at least someone
who's like semi-famous and that becoming
something that everyone relates to and
then there's 10 guardian articles about
it about how this is about abuse of
women this is about men being this this
is about women being this
like sometimes things just happen to
individual people and i get it but it
doesn't have to be a societal trend not
everything has to be
yes that's happening in society and
therefore it's happening everywhere and
that's globally everyone's experience
and if you don't relate you're the
problem if you don't understand it you
don't forget that they were like
yeah johnny depp winning this case has
just set all women back it's like just
do you really think we like the idea
that we're comparing johnny depp
to all men or amber heard to all women
good little catch up uh hopefully you
guys enjoyed this thanks a lot to our
sponsors for today as well appreciate
you guys
in the comments
check the link in the description if you
do care about us we need you to back our
sponsors this is important these guys
are looking after us we want you to look
after them they're also a product we
believe in which is yeah they're
actually very reputable and very uh very
handy to have actually a really great
app as well yeah go for it guys
thanks for watching we appreciate you
don't forget to hit that like button
stay subscribed thanks and we'll see you
on the next one